a big-time you to ACB MMA they are
putting on a massive event in Sheffield
on the 22nd of July including former UFC
fighter Thiago Silva is going to be
there the light heavyweight title is
going to be on the line and tickets are
just 20 pounds each I'm going to put the
link in the description below if you
want to go there use that link and the
big songs to ACB once again for getting
Frank Mir on the true jory podcast right
big moment for me met a former UFC
heavyweight [__] champion yeah is on
my podcast especially at this point
we're getting to a big point in the
podcast we're at 50 yeah well cut the 50
minutes a great way to mark a big way to
do it front me on it thumbs up very much
for knowledge are really appreciative
been great so far I like at the end of a
car I was good yeah what a good love me
I mean there was been a bit squeezing
the buckle to sort of realize but I like
that you understand me because you're a
big guy yes you think I am so when you
call the pakora cause of the minivan
know that sometimes they have this
argument people like to exact travel
rewards booking economy kick you
tomorrow hmm
look man I'm not being a [__] prima
donna
no they think you being a snuggle right
they'll take off first I want time here
and all I see go you want us to business
class I don't see business Scott seems
like a vice president of all [__]
you're five foot [__] ten in the
[__] on you should only weigh 180
pounds where your shoulders are still
just bigness put me in the back of my
camera sorry I mean yeah I'm on top of
everybody
yeah yeah large make sure that big mini
banking we lead with the elbows like
[__] hit trouble and there is a us
[__] in here
yeah it's also a big man we can add it
on the see what I get
Uber's everywhere so like that's good
for me but if we get in the back of an
uber uber driver looks like normally
just you know you get Anna back the car
you don't really make uncomfortable when
he gets in the car goes driving us we
look in the back in Brian's is like a
bit of a hit when they get in the back
of an uber
well if the seat and passenger sides put
really far back in a cart leg get me
legs and I really get annoyed yeah - I
mean I [__] help me it was a fever
but yeah I mean 15 years you've been in
the UFC yeah not many people can say
that not many people can say that they
were like literally top fives in that
division the whole [__] time pretty
much you always want to take away from
fighting for the title it's not fighting
for the title children I mean you're an
elite level fighter but you were a part
of the UFC before the Conor McGregor era
where everyone now seems to think it's
all about money and the gentleman and it
wasn't like that when you got in it was
it was called human cockfighting there
was a [__] bloodsport everyone else
you were in it when it was like feed
like what the hell made you think I'll
do this well I always liked martial art
of exciting like competing in um you
know it was a way for me to go out there
and compete against other guys that know
how to fight not have to worry about
anybody want to follow me out to my car
afterwards in fairness you agree to it
and so uh when I first had my first
professional fight in 2001 with UFC I
never thought I'd make a living at it in
fact I was still working as a bouncer or
the star was about to add es Spearmint
Rhino I kept that job all weapon to our
fabric because it helped because we
never made enough money of being a
fighter for me to support a family and
kids is it true that the UFC so from
when people admit not because they say
that the UFC have sold us people to not
like I know Shane Carwin was a mechanic
and they sort of try to pay money to
quit his jobs because they didn't want
it to be known that some fighters are
still having to do regular jobs while
fighting lost well and then summated
sillies try to think that because very
few fighters can make a living just off
fighting I mean if you think about you
have a fighter that makes 15 thousand
dollars a fight there seems like good
money taxes training partners to the
camp you know by the time you pay your
manager you typically get half of what
you're making you know and so $7,000
well if you fight three times a year
that's good for a guy who may be 19
years old lives in an apartment but to
make you know $20,000 a year but a guy
who wants to be married and have
children there was no way you know you
can't and that's why actually you're
starting to see a lot less jujitsu guys
go into fighting and actually Robert
drives alone the guys I trained with he
brought it up like why why don't we see
more juice two guys going into it and
goes if you're just it to guide you when
mundial you have a gold medal he goes
okay now you can go on do seminars you
know you make a couple thousand dollars
let's say you only make $25 a week doing
seminars private lessons training travel
around you can make almost $10,000 a
month and that's $120,000 a year job how
are you ever going to say hey give up
three or four months a year of seminars
cut your pay in half and then we'll pay
you you know four and four you know go
fight your first fight even you know
fifteen six but another thing was like
but in the day they had sponsorship
opportunities the UFC way you could have
I don't know bad boy might sponsor your
shots and things that I make money off
that they've literally killed that now
for a lot of fighters through this
Reebok deal that they've introduced way
it's compulsory that everyone in the UFC
weighs Reebok so Reebok are then going
to give the the line shade to the UFC
and it's up to them what they give the
fires again ya know I mean it's
profitable to do see is profitable to
the you know Reebok or if it's not
they're done businessman because it's on
them they did it it is so I'm hoping
they're making a profit off it or we're
all just getting screwed because all the
fighters are we all to pick ups most
people don't want to hear it's funny
well only the week of the fight and into
the fight you have to you know wear
Reebok well me as I was growing up
fighting you had a lot of people that
would sponsor you monthly and that would
help pay your bills and carry over and
take care of things but then for the
payoff they got to put a patch on your
shorts or in your banner the night of
the fight well then Reebok killed that
it's like oh hey they can sponsor you
it's like why would they why would they
who are they reaching out to just my
social media
they wanted to reach out to people on
the platform the UFC's provide you so it
really did put a announ the confident i
think you're going to see a lot of the
fighters really starting to you know the
great of maybe go places with the aura
level sponsors like Bellator i guess
yeah ACB you know risen you know you
name it will series of fighting there'll
be other organizations that don't hinder
and hamstring the guys so in the target
i mean until the young guy that he has
to give up a thousand two thousand
dollars a month sponsor that's a massive
money here but he did it and then then
now we have to wear the Reebok shorts
his first fight is it make $2,500 yeah
the wear the shorts like that's rough
yeah and you sort of wonder why they did
it
like why go down that route luck in all
those people out I don't know I mean you
know I think that in hindsight that when
they're preparing you know they didn't
sell the UFC in three days when they
were preparing to want to sell it I
think that packaging it up made sense
yeah and then also to it just showed
more revenue on their part so when they
have the UFC um which is what I'm
looking for
not audited but you know values dieter
yeah they say okay how much is worse
well then the Reebok contract out slow
so many millions of dollars okay well we
have that revenue coming in teach it's
like a football club and sponsorship
with like real the treasurer adidas or
something like that like an odds value
straight yeah but then Ramage would have
got that Rama Droid compete in La Liga
they can get sponsored by anyone then
they're the league is sponsored by
someone Ramage's sponsored by someone
else that's workers football players you
can have a boot sponsor who's totally
different you're allowed to wear like
make boots if you're the stripper
sponsored by Diaz whereas these UFC
fighters have just been completely
[__] I do think that's part of it as
well though is in football you tend to
find that the brands will all work
directly with the players so you know
mess he's got his own boots but he's a
head of a brand all the other players
get personally fitted boots they work
with the brand they get feedback on the
boots and Mosul and it's kind of thing
you don't see so I just wonder if what
like you know all those brands realize
that we're going to have to do this
because players are angry otherwise that
they just get a generic pair of
boots surely would be good free but went
down the same Bruton sore said like you
know we'll find a way of fitting you
know what everybody's well it's like
they have a few you know about a couple
fighters up there to give ideas but but
it's still broadly distributed isn't
just every fighter gets a particularly
pick out how he wants a shorts and and
on you know or t-shirt or is outfit and
the other part that actually confuses me
I don't see how rebirth makes money off
of it have you guys seen any walk around
everyone I've never seen anyone got a
pair Reebok trainers not longer I'm
going to say they're the best things I
don't know what the MMA branded like so
the McGregor or Ronda Rousey are they
trying to sell people would rather buy
regular McGregor t-shirt like you you
would see like his own t-shirt rather
than a Reebok one because I think
there's also there's I mean to be honest
in the UK there's also going to be only
a certain kind of people are going to
wear that sort of thing because UFC
isn't still not quite penetrating on the
majors really anywhere yeah exactly it's
still seen as it it's almost seen as
like a sort of a rough guy member cutler
year score when taco was everywhere
affliction Reebok haven't done that with
the MMA crowd at all they haven't
crossed over so yeah what I've seen
application since I've been here walking
down the street yeah but I'm not sure
they wanna break into that area I think
they're happy to have like a premium
brand where they make margin on some
things where they're selling to
middle-class guys who are trying to get
fit in
what's that CrossFit that's a happy
trying to sell to those guys and this
just makes it look like look what one
day I can look like you you know what I
mean because if you train enough and you
know you're rough and you're tough then
you know you can get what one thing that
sort of surprised was me when I hear
about the communication between company
and fighter in the UFC is how little
communication via times I go there was a
woman fight I just got our title strip
from a Jimmy derived American image she
found out on to us like they didn't they
are are I think the same thing happened
there Conor McGregor when he lost the
featherweight title you know like what
is it like being a fighter in the UFC
working with the company like is it for
straighten do you feel like they could
do more in that respect like if they
could but as of right now um you know
they kinda I think have
the mindset that what are you going to
do mmm
I think that's going to change because
you know people are talking about Latour
a lot more those are the shows like the
ACB that are coming up that are sitting
there going we'll there's a fighter
right now I think Dean Garnett there
that was going to you know that had an
opportunity to possibly go from ACB to
the UFC for a four-fight deal he looked
at the contract what they had to offer
him and decided it was more lucrative
and better for him stay with the ACB
you're certain start hearing those
stories occurring more and more awful
because they have the monopoly for years
and years it's all remains a bit like
the old wrestling days with the WWE
absolutely WCW once obviously EE came
along and provided an alternative of the
people our children ship life right and
so I do think we're probably going to
say a lot more of them
what's my glory I've got all them people
like that cool as good business anytime
you dominate the business field why do
you have to make adjustments why do you
have to ignore aliy right like not like
that's that's you know a lot of more of
those dismiss
no that's I'm saying it's like that's
why that's why some people would that's
that's the argument people put forward
right like they want to make their own
industry they're like certain certain
sports companies they they still rely on
like a ddos rely on the idea they were
set up by Adi Dassler
and so they run it as they wanted they
want to be good for the athletes now you
could say that's marketing or whatever
it probably is and they've afforded
themselves that space because they were
ahead of everyone else but they say like
they want to afford sports do you know
what I mean oh then you can make that
it's it's proven you can make money off
selling yourself like that not true and
I think the biggest thing for for a
customer is competition yeah you know if
somebody has the only product in town
they don't have to really listen to what
you have to say about it yeah it's funny
they make the fighters compete but they
don't want to rebut want zero
competition amongst themselves that's
good it matter to you what you weigh in
stirrin um yeah I mean I have my own
personality I would like to express
adding that the fans even if they don't
get you know upset with the fact that we
have to I mean we take pay cuts just the
individuality of the sport has been
killed everybody dresses exactly the
same so you know guys have very little
choice between
loose-fitting shorts are tied towards is
about as much of a choice as you get
we're in the past people you can see
their personalities through how they
dress into the far into the cage didn't
matter to you though I mean do you think
though do you think it's a it's a
particularly cold impersonal yeah you
know just like anything else if you go
to the gym if I just you up in a way
anyone be dressed yeah you don't feel
the same way when you're working out
like it makes a slight difference you
know if you get to pick what you want to
wear and wait how do you want to know
what shoes you mean when you go buy a
pair of trainers picking the trainers I
mean you're not just purely picking them
with your eyes closed one okay these
feel right you look at me see how they
look on you these that feel-good feeling
tributes to more success yeah that's
actually really good the YouTube video
idea buying things just and feeling them
yeah so like that down so you've got I
think they were right and again you got
into martial law through your dad yeah
and a lot of your fights wasn't he was
that the father-son bond a big part of
martial arts for you well I think I got
into martial arts because you know and I
think a lot of boys try to emulate their
father and then you know he was a fan of
martial arts so you know I'd ask
questions movies I've looked at and he
you know he guided me that way and so uh
you know then eventually they became my
own thing you know now I share with my
children did you have any moments as a
teenager well evil crota because
obviously would be one of the biggest
guys your age where you have that sort
of Karate Kid Daniel Larusso Multan
flick someone tried on anyone or karate
[__] advocated those moments
everybody knew I knew how to do stuff
you know playing off my friends and
stuff and in a few fights but I think
the finally when the school was my
junior high school I got into a fight
real bad we were playing American
football playing around after school and
some older guys out of high school you
know by many years they came over to
play and there was being dicks and one
of the guys Iran you know we're playing
tackle then I was on the ground and as I
went to get up with the guy hit me again
you know knocked me down so I got right
up and just kicked him in the face and
just sort of fighting he went down
easily
then his buddy kind of squared up on me
and you know
he was still in a Stanton that I could
shoot at him too and then so afterwards
you know I mean when you're you know 16
years old and you beat the [__] out of a
20 year old me on two of them at the
same time it became like a big deal gets
around doesn't it have you always been
you've always been a big guy that yeah
always been big which actually I think
helped me be coordinated you know I was
I never grew anymore in height after my
freshman year of high school probable
that I've been so 13 years old all right
so you were like 6 foot 3 2 and a half
Wow anyway you know I think muscle mass
me 13 MIDI no no I was like 210 pounds
Wow and then you know but I mean it's a
reasonable very skinny and then uh by
the time I was a senior in high school I
weighed 250 is that family thing but is
that gonna do you get that is it saying
my dad's and I looked the same he's just
a smaller version right okay they don't
make my dad I'm diggin but that's that's
what I do find funny and that's that's
what a lot of people don't really
acknowledge there's a certain parts of
America where people seem to grow up
bigger Ivan says people in taxes just
think of people to not only include yeah
get the food where you don't think so
yeah it's what it's basically what how
they feed you is yeah right you know all
the hormones right yeah basically this
he your father huh giggles yeah
relatives were all drug free technically
but my studs in the cuff ya know I make
jokes about that all the time my father
never would sit down you look at us and
our man you isms just our facial
structures like I can't deny ya know
there's no doubt that I'm his child but
I you know except for he didn't weigh
over 200 pounds until he was in his 40s
yes and so you know the joke is always
there who's the mouth BAM yeah but I
mean obviously you know there's no no
denying it and so do you think you
instantly took the fighting you can all
have naturally don't have a fighting
personality um I'm very passive by
nature and even in my first couple
fights early in my career you've seen
that I was very much of a [__] you know
it was most big men are what do you mean
well you mean like that that if you're
big and strong and a good athlete and
you get put in adversity most people
crush right because I'm so used to being
on the beat everybody up so easily
yeah so the first couple of times that
someone resisted and was able to fight
back that it made me panic and then
because of martial arts being such a
great you know format to train your mind
failure I searched out how to reach
success and we was that like a conscious
thing did you bring someone in it was
that personal genuine traversal okay
find a lot of jiu-jitsu artists tend to
be about winning the fight without
actually causing major damage it's about
getting to the submission and like the
MMA our style I guess is causing very
little violence within the fights funny
because actually it looks incredibly
violent bad snap Amanda as far as Frank
got through his career the violence
certainly the increase so yeah there's
nothing quite extreme about it that like
if you see a limb which looks like it's
about to rip out of its socket there's
something really a highlights video I'm
not a huge UFC Fan like from the
convenience but like I was watching the
highlights pretty clear of the day most
of the videos are extreme angles of you
on and ripping someone's arm out or like
the other group yeah that'll or ripping
someone's arm out yeah you was like I
guess I mean some people may put the the
gym up there but you were the
heavyweight king of submissions really
well I'm actually I think as far as the
submission aspect of game goes on I am
the best um you know this guys might
have better Jiu Jitsu different aspects
of it but that's sexy know he's a better
bar to us but but who's the best
knockout knows and as far as that goes I
think the men there was a there was a
was always that question between a lot
of fight funds of there was a Antonio
Nogueira and Frank Nia they had to fight
the first fight you'd really evolved
your stand up so much it was kind of
mouth guard it was quite easy for you
actually it was shopping because for a
big guy you are really light on your
feet and you were bounce and all and he
couldn't you weren't stand still for a
second he couldn't pin you and you just
beat the crap over and then the excuses
came from odd staph infection it'd be
fair no gear I definitely put up a
better show and for a period of time in
the second fight he started he table
viously work on his stand-up because he
knew how good you become but to break
rot like Nogueira zom was a the ultimate
statement a lot of people viewed him as
someone you looked up do so then to the
student became the master basically in
that fight it was a now such an example
of me over coming over
city and learning how to deal with it
because he caught me with a good shot
and I was hurt and the old me that
started out that the way I was born
probably would have folded up and you
know guy it's done but the new you know
what I created through hard training and
through you know trial and error was
somebody that didn't think about what
was happening like oh how did I get to
this point and how am I gonna get at
this point I just thought about where
I'm at right now
so I just identified every move ok ha
I'm gonna choke how do I get out of it
you know sweet
I hope there's a zone to take that ok
move to the next is not sitting that
feeling sorry for yourself when I can't
even get my ass kicked
you've naturally a good problem solver
yeah I've always been because I think
well the most important thing about them
being good at anything is liking it and
I like solving issues you know me like
everything you know I'll see your
problem well you know even arguing with
somebody or having a discussion I try to
look for solutions people who have
passion for something will always in my
opinion be better than someone who is
almost forced into it even if they work
exactly the same that's a great
framework but then some people say well
obviously breaking some alarm is not a
solution so how do you get over that
resolution no no you know you know me
about it's not you know your if you're
talking about looking for an argument
with the way of thinking what I'm trying
to do is get to a point so what I'm
saying to you is like how do you get
into the mindset of looking for the
solution of breaking someone's arm
because it's not a positive outcome for
everyone
do you know no well because it's the
same thing as if someone's in front of
me dribbling the ball and I can't
dribble with you so I sweep the legs out
from underneath you sure I'm not being
malicious I'm not trying to break your
legs but that's a viable solution for me
to defeat what you're doing yeah I mean
yeah you know you've seen all the time
in different sports where people have to
make contact with each other I can't be
a complete passage of this and say well
I'm not going to hurt you well then find
a different sport really exactly yes and
so is portative wise when I lock
something up on you I'm trying to apply
pressure to where if the limbs going to
break if you don't top and you have a
solution to get out so that's why I've
never been mad because I've never I've
never after person referee to stop the
fight gave an extra right I've never
been that guy that oh you're only
feeling still
oh no the timer point my point is to try
to disable the body yeah now it's one
less thing I have to worry about so if
we're fighting and I break your shoulder
if you don't tap and the referee doesn't
stop the fight okay so now I go back to
let me how do I get to his neck because
I know if I cut the blood off to your
brain you lose consciousness and not
have one less time to worry about to me
it's not it's not really true violence
because there was no animosity behind it
I'm not mad at you I'm not trying to
make it to a year you know and you
agreed to this you know we both sit
there and we'll click American rules
football there was a lot of mutual
respect between you and Nogueira as well
it wasn't a bad blood sort of fight
really but there are there have been
instances where you have been in the
situation where there is a certain
amount of animosity is that you do you
feel different going to those fightin no
not at all as soon as the fights start
to keep my mind clear just the task at
hand this I think anytime you have an
emotional predetermination to something
it causes distraction and I want to have
my mind as clear as possible to see
exactly what's in front I don't remember
you ever getting rattled before a fight
I can't remember one fight where you
went in the shouting angry guy you
always seemed like that clear no so I
can see the you know I can make reads I
go here go here do this and in that
moment when Nogueira's lying there on
the floor he'd broken his arm that there
was shock in the MMA community like
we've seen something that nobody really
ever liked expected to say front me I
had broken Nogueira's on like Nogueira
was like the grandfather almost as was
Niels like the submission game in the
heavyweight division and pride in that
how did that feel when I was doing it
well also yeah the whole it proved from
what the moment you did it after well I
think how it felt when I did it do the
same as somebody I'm in America smokes
easier for me make the analogy you
tackle somebody with the ball yeah no I
have you had the ball I hit you yeah and
then afterwards you know during the game
he gets hurt okay you're hurt I take a
knee get them off the planes heal them
go back to being a competitive then
obviously when I go home you know and
I'm relaxed I remember
when it happened I looked over another
guy man I wish you would have tapped
earlier yeah in fact I never felt him
tap at all because by the time he
laughed I'd already broken his limb and
he was tapping between my legs and I
didn't notice it
yeah but I was looking at the referee so
that way I knew that it was already past
the point of no return I wanted to be
able as soon as I felt him coming in I
could let go because no matter what
happens if I stopped before the referee
stops it it doesn't count
yeah so you can see as I'm doing it me
looking up there are free like all right
I know where this is going when can we
stop you know and so uh when it happened
no problem because that's the frame of
mind I'm and it's like being on the
football field
tackling somebody but that went to the
grocery store if you said hey hit that
old lady on my client I'm not enough
frame of mind right now she walked in
the cage go ahead me I'm gonna break
your shoulder she fell better
so as funny as I went home and our
friends of mine Cape the fight you know
for us so y'all sit down the wife and
they want to watch it with me so sitting
there watching it and as you see the arm
going I started doing the whole [__] you
know and then like it breaks and I jerk
my wife looked at me she says look you
know what I did I do and did it I'm like
I'm gonna different friend of mine right
now you know I'm home I'm with my wife
my kids
I'm not dog again yeah I mean I'm not
him you know I feel like that's the guy
that fights you I mean I'm sure you
could see someone in the bar you use a
situation we're gonna have a good time
laughing and also know my god [__] I got
a fight you know then all right
I'm fight mode now I may have to hurt
somebody yeah so in and you know that's
very deliberate for me though
compartmentalizing those things that you
don't cross those over yeah and I think
that most people have to yeah you know
you have a different frame of mind that
when you are hunting than you do when
you just home with your children even a
hunter you know out in the woods you
have a different mindset then you're
going to have when you relax you put
your guard down your home you know
you're talking if you're hanging out if
you're out in the and the bushes and you
were talking with your buddies hanging
out you ain't gonna hit [__] all the
animals are running away anyway there's
to be a different kind of focus for me
use silence so many doubters that night
like I think you cemented your legacy at
that point of one of the Great's with
that with that moment they'd already
done so much but that was like all that
was [__] immense did you ever get any
emotion towards people who dealt with
you in the past where you wanted to real
people's face in it or you wanted to
have that well look look what I [__]
done I told you I was the number one
like you know know me here's the thing
it's funny I hear people say ignore the
critics don't listen to the naysayers
and that is really shitty advice it
really is listen to everything bad or
good be thick-skinned enough to deal
with it don't be a [__] and cry about
everything you hear about yourself but
those critics and naysayers not the
idiot to just go
second deck is everything all right we
don't have to earlier but if they're
like oh man you suck at X Y & Z yeah
well [__] do I like a look at and go
well yeah I do need to work here well I
do have this shortcoming there and then
sometimes the people that love you that
you want to listen to they don't want to
tell you well I'm not going to say that
you know I actually Frank the way you
talk in the situation you know kind of
makes you look you know we're here
someone else got mo-fuckers an [__]
like I will what are you talking about
yeah so listening to critics it's like a
I just seen an actress that Kate Winslet
she's a girl you know they told me I was
too fat you know I couldn't do it I'm
like so you're telling the fat girl at
home to ignore that advice no listen to
that advice yeah people are calling you
too fat do something about it I mean
like or find some way to make that
adjustment but sitting there I'm just
ignore you so I can march on I'm like
well can't you listen to people it hurts
you're feeling a little bit yeah but
he's one of the exceptions that came
from the actual right but so then you
listened to the advice and like okay and
now drive forward with it and use it as
ammo to help make yourself a better
person it sounds like you're very good
at separating the emotion from the
situation's and thinking from a more of
an analytical standpoint well you try to
as much as possible not that my feelings
don't also get hurt sometimes I made
that [__] human um but you just you
can't let it paralyze you there has to
be balance if you think about it nothing
is life works without
balance you can't sit there go I'm gonna
ignore everybody all right well that's
not gonna be very useful you have no
insight you're never gonna have any
other perspectives to come in and tell
you and show you what's going on you're
like I'm going to listen everybody in
the well [__] man now you have too much
information coming and now you're
overloaded there has to be a healthy
medium and all things yeah you social
media can be good if you're on your
phone in the middle of night 3:00 in the
morning because you you know it's
overkill yeah at the same time sometimes
I'm the victim of that you know that I
don't really like social media I really
don't I like talking to people in person
so I actually just learned yesterday how
to retweet Wow I had no clue like if you
say they retweet this I'm like I have no
[__] - none whatsoever by god man
because I'll post things I thought that
was good enough and I'm like now you
needed interact more mom I honestly
don't know how - yeah you could [__]
sir
even when I fought Todd Duffee like he's
singing this - you saying this about
your mom on what is all Twitter a mom
[__] if you told her right now a nuclear
bomb was coming in an hour and you
posted it on Twitter I'm fund reduction
in the cafe go well [__] down man I have
no idea that's really interesting I mean
not that is that something again that
you sort of naturally always thought
away so there's a family thing that came
through or if you develop that well I
don't like talking on the phone to
people either like all my friends and
family know if you keep me on the phone
for more than 60 seconds I'm like yeah
yeah I don't want to be on the phone I
hate the other
I love texting I just got when I wrong
yesterday yeah all right yes no bye I'm
very book than most for the rating oh
yeah but now look we're here talking I
will shut the [__] up yeah I like
talking to people
I'll have an interaction with you your
own podcast so yeah I do full boost
Fightin's if you don't drive I mean
there's a hunter I'm folding fighting
down in my house twice weekly and we
talk but if you just have me just
talking to fans I don't know I can't see
you I need to see you and feel you and
just alright and get a read off you and
you to be me and I'm good with that but
it's fine
so probably the fact that like I suck on
the phone like I said texting to me is
awesome one or two sentences gets the
whole point it comes I at the same
conversation with somebody and they want
to
for two minutes I'm like holy [__] man I
just wasted a minute a half of my life
listen to you on the phone you could
have just said I'm going to pick you up
here are you hungry
I'll be were done done yes yeah some
people do I know there's a there's
everyone in London at the moment I don't
know if it's a min America is obsessed
with sending voice notes so like record
a three-minute voice note but I had a
10-minute voice note from someone the
other day and I was like I'm just not
going to listen to this you can't send
me a 10-minute audio message and expense
I was like so mega text I'll skim it and
if it's interesting to me then I'll
aren't sorry guys I have a friend of
mine so such wrong moment you'll come to
there I know I can I don't look the same
if I tell someone don't good I think it
like you and it sometimes the
international forum you'll leave me a
voicemail yes and I'll show you how long
the voicemail is and if it's longer than
15 seconds I believed you like I
probably have had like you're gonna die
of cancer next year like do that you
know have you left it for the 15 seconds
oh my god like we're sending a man to
kill you oh my god the 16 second message
my son a baby someone just got we're
gonna caddy bike yeah I'm like if you
can't get your point across in 15
seconds you're probably rambling if not
an elevator pitch what you need is all
your ideas and out of HP yeah right
there boom go yeah I've seen those with
a three minutes longer I look at them
all I hope he's not telling me his dad's
goods I'll never know so the thing is
now other people know that they're not
going to try you're not doing that why
definitely have both my friends knows
right because they'll say hey I look to
message amongst the three minute one
like yeah well I deleted yeah I'll never
look bad yeah look what did you need
well I was just seeing what you're up to
this we would go riding this week in the
mall that took three minutes to figure
out well yeah I'm like nah man [__] hey
man
call me this Sunday we're gonna go for
ride you want to go look out question
actually picking it up I was actually
going to mention that because when you
first won the heavyweight title you Tim
Sylvia there you had a motorcycle
accident after that and they they took
the title off you because you were quite
badly injured when you your resilience
must have [__] come into play a big
time then because you had a lot of rehab
and stuff like that to do didn't you
yeah there was big questions about wrong
at this point like
when you first came back were like
because you were I don't know like The
Prodigy like you this young guy who's
just ripping through people and then is
he ever going to be the same again I
will be at that point 24 okay you are
finishing fights you're killing people
off easily and now now around us in a
minute so much questions over like can
you ever come back from this how did you
manage that and how bad was it when it
was rad I'm else to just you know
because physically I wasn't the same for
many many years uh it took away
different tools that I had relied upon
the knowledge that I had - okay here you
know this problem you gotta get over
that wall alright okay but now you don't
have the ability to jump oh [__]
I was just jumped up and grabbed it well
you're still going over the wall you
can't jump this high now so um that
created many problems that you know that
I think you know always urge that that's
why I tell people to us all you inspire
me I'm like okay it's not a this is not
a movie I didn't have one point we're
like it's [__] [__] [__] [__] [__] and
then all I had an eye-opening experience
and then everything went right let's
wave people about unit Elizabeth how
they think about this so then I realize
I'm like look I would have good days and
bad days yeah and it's just constant up
and down battle and knowing that when
you're having a bad day that just you
know fight through it and then you'll
catch the moment of a good day but don't
lose despair when you gain momentum and
all of a sudden you hit another wall you
know it's not like well [__] I tried no
no keep trying till you die figure out a
way to move through it if that
frustration get to you at all many times
I'm in fact one time I specifically went
to my wife after fighting or lost it was
like you know I just don't have it I
mean look we're trying you know it's
just not working out and then she you
know then you know thankfully was able
to sit there go you know you're wrong
you know um you know I can't believe
that you're acting this way right now
you know I've seen you in your moments
of strength and that guy would not would
be ashamed of this person that's looking
at meanwhile right now that's that's
true let's be very honest yeah
I mean some people especially a bloke
who looks like you would love another
courage to be that honest with you but
that's the whole example tough love is
my and that's one thing I
love about my wife is that you know it's
funny cuz it has causes problems and she
stuck to her guns and and she's actually
had the best explanation for it in one
sense she's very much my manager you
know she's kind of like my keeper like
no Frank don't eat that no Frank can't
go [__] jump out of an airplane
tomorrow you know II know you know and
then now you know I don't have a very
good personality for that my personality
is very much you can explain to me why
but you can't tell me no let me make
that decision you know I don't like
authority over the top of me and so huh
I've always been that kid where if
you're like everybody has to go to the
left I start going to the right and I
rolled you just [__] told me to go
this way I have to I can't help it
there's something in my chest
telling me to to do not do what you're
asking me to do but if you give me a
good explanation I will so and once this
we have to put that hat on her and I
have had some very ugly confrontations
verbally you know and then then she has
to put the hat on where she is my wife
and it's hard because then I'm still
looking at the same exact person yeah
but she's like well no that was me as
the manager talking to you about how you
dealt with this situation because it's
not the right way now I'm your wife I
support whatever you do I love you feels
like what God it's very hard and yes and
I give her a lot of credit for that
because I see so many other spouses and
significant others that don't want to
tell their loved one what they don't
want to hear because it's [__] fight
oh yeah oh you know I'm going to tell
the missus that she's put 20 pounds on
it's probably not good for their I
should be upset about their good [__]
luck with that one your name but earlier
my wife will come to mingle
[__] you look fat right now what the
hell like this night all we need to do
something about that where you know as
my wife she's just like look I'm happy
with you you're so attractive you know
me like I don't give a [__] so she goes
but if you want that sponsor from that
company you can't look like that yeah so
she told you basically you can't you
still got it and she was right
ultimately obviously you went on the
field but I mean it's funny cuz then I'm
sure they go how the [__] do you know
you know really like from the outside
you're watching but I know what if you
know let's look at results
I know because sometimes I could be very
pessimistic without through them very
statistical I look at it you know I do
say hey we're going to jump out of this
helicopter land in the water when I swim
over there I'm like alright what is the
chance of this working
15% [__] you yeah get the coach out
there closer we get those guys that are
just gun hole optimistic toward [__] it
I could do it I'm not that guy I'm all
know Jesus said 15% I'm not [__]
jumping out of this thing you know which
is ironic though because to be a fighter
you've got to shut that voice off once
you get in the cage and be convinced
that you're gonna win I guess like where
is your don't think so not know it
because then if you're convinced you're
going to win you're ignoring facts right
I've walked in the fights going [__] he
has a higher percentage of winning than
I do and this is why I'm doing the math
in my head okay is there anywhere I can
make adjustments can i okay
where if you had the higher percentage
will here or over there if it goes here
okay so I know I need to take it here
where now I have a 40% chance of winning
you know I've increased the odds because
I've identified you just once again
can't be paralyzed with facts just
because you see a line in the room if
there are the chances of winning are
slim why is bigger stronger as teeth all
right so I've acknowledged that you can
eat me well what if I grabbed the stance
over there and I put a stick on the in
it well not a guarantee for victory but
you've increased your chances now and so
I and then now it's like okay well now
just do what you have to do without
looking at the facts but you have to
address them until the very moment of
confrontation because it's like an more
you can't sit there any time a general
in war if you go through histories of
war goes we're just going to drive
through it look at Hitler when he
destroyed the the German army wasn't
like you know what we're going to attack
or after the even there he goes hey man
Russian winter not a good idea
but that bravado that alarms should push
through it we're instead if he had been
more like me going [__] that's kind of
scary we're not going to go that way or
the Japanese going to help us look now
we're not communicating with them very
well
okay well why don't we fixed and have
them go this way and we'll pause and
hang out here because my chances of
going through that are probably not very
good his wife wasn't as good as you yeah
I guess for good / I guess good thing we
all kind of won out of our baggage would
not be happening well because then you
know I mean that's my thing about God
for Hitler's wife's being socially an
the main reason - yeah it was all her
[__] up ultimately when you look but it
was alright though I mean if you look at
like Churchill as well Churchill had a
pretty staunch wife Mae okay you know
and he's got some great quotes as well
there was one woman who said to him if I
was your wife I'd been poisoning your
teeth and he was like to do my wife a
drink in a bed lines of all time good
essentially happy having a good marriage
is working well it helps have a good
partner in life you don't have somebody
that supports you and is willing to tell
you what you know might not be the
prettiest thing in the world how long
you've into them 15 years now
so pretty much UFC or your fighting life
yva man yeah we were dating my second
fight in the UFC how does she deal with
it when you get in the optimum because I
saw this before on my five videos is a
heavyweight level you it's not like the
light weight of the featherweight in
that way you see unbeaten runs for 10:25
some days because when they get the chin
check there's a much better chance of
surviving that and getting it out and
that's why Mighty Mouse is gonna defeat
for so long and people like that was the
heavyweight level you make a mistake you
pay for it and you pay for drastically
I have my wife that's really worried
about me in her cage she's seen worse
battles and injuries occurring in
practice really her biggest fear is that
if I fail how long and in that night is
really in a case anymore before when I
was younger I would fail your army to
start myself angry despair there would
be that three or four days of just like
[__] only the house you know I'm just
and then you know Dakar I'm a deter and
in her mind I understand she's like okay
the world's been put on hold for eight
weeks I just want to have my husband
back I don't want the fighter anymore I
just want to be able to go out go to the
pool go to eat dinner and not have
fighting consumed are wolves and if you
who's talking when I win it's still that
way so she wants me to shut that down
should I do a much better job of that
now acknowledging that like once the
fights over with whatever happens the
next week or two is hers
it reminds a guy what you want to do so
I've been in places in Disneyland black
eyes act towards put on sunglasses go
with the Union that's because she wins
really doesn't she at the end she gets
you back running
yeah which is this huge positive payoff
right she first of those realizes the
life has to go on and you saying she
loves him worse in dreaming training I
was I was sort of curious about this
because you know obviously you make so
many people tap out how do you train to
do that sort of thing because obviously
you can't get someone else in the ring
you go I'm gonna break your arm now or I
think it being honest with yourself what
you're training for I don't train it put
people in pain I trained the lock up a
solid move right that I've trained
enough to know that okay if I do this
it's going to break your shoulder so in
training I go for this and then the
person taps Diane you know my training
partners know to acknowledge it and did
you have a feeling for that like you
know when you know when you break
someone's arm but your feeling for when
you sort of done it right yeah
this is just like a chiropractor working
on some bright I know the body well
enough and just do so many years I have
a feel I can tell when I have something
I shook his hand before this is genuine
truth and you're backing up better or
not this is a genuine truth though the
[__] know masculine manly sure I
grip like I've never felt me [__]
life and it's not like you are I was
right what I mean is you ain't squeezing
on me hand anything but I've never put
my hand in another man's hand in my
entire life and felt like I had a small
hand
mm-hm until the day swings I felt I had
a huge hammer that's interesting now I
mean that's you did you develop that
feel like when you first started
fighting though you know do you sort of
you're more numb to it now you feel like
you've owned that in a way or if you're
like anything I think of any athletic
endeavor you have a more of an
understanding your body learns more feel
just the more reps who you that's really
interesting one thing I think is
interesting is in the pre Conor McGregor
era
because I feel like he's he has changed
the game and that in terms of bringing
so many more eyes on the sport Ritz
promoter Weaver a great talk I had no
doubt about in the hell of a fighter but
before then I have to say in my opinion
the one fight that brought more eyes to
the UFC than ever in the history because
I remember this feeling because I was a
UFC fun since the Ortiz Ken Shamrock
fights long long time before this fight
happened but I remember as a college and
there was the you tube on and all of the
lads really like 20 years old all the
lads around this computer Nolan [__]
hell have you seen this and it was you
Tupper know Brock Lesnar and that fight
first time the first fight the first one
in particular because he'd been a pro
wrestler but he was obviously a hell of
an athlete and he had such a massive
name and then a guy the fight was
amazing it was like literally he thought
was going on me then it was gone the
other I was classic fight that brought
more eyes for the UFC than I think any
fight pre Conor McGregor ever what was
it like to be a part of that from start
to finish out of the field you know it's
funny up until about two or three days
before the fight I wish you remember who
told it to me in the Mac I was taking it
very much like alright you know fight
the fight I'm always out there just to
test myself that's why I'd never really
cared about who I fight there just a
dance partner right but if you like to
dance you don't sit there a night at the
club going alright who might find a
night to go dancing do you like to dance
you like to dance I just need someone
else to do it with me I genuinely like
fighting you know I think fighting is
fun if I thought that people aren't
going to stab me or try to shoot me or
follow me home afterwards I didn't do a
fight every night at the pub loiter
wherever we want to fight [__] let's
fight you're hearing this is awesome and
we're all said and done we sit down and
drink and hang out and go home we're
their wives
Fight Club style basically I like to
fight identify mean is fun you know it's
fun whether you get rocked and you are
gaming it's not me just trying to beat
you I like fighting when you losing
fighting this you know is something I
enjoy doing
and so uh I didn't think much of it is
so for another flight you know
I was in the back you know cuz you do
all those immediate stuff leading up to
the fight and I'm walking through when
they of the fighters stopping goes I'm
an you know you're representing our son
right he's a pro wrestler we're fighters
you know basically all of MMA is on your
shoulders right now a little bit like
what Connors gone through against Floyd
I guess yeah and so as soon as I'm
walking away from I'm like oh my wait a
minute I remember I turned around from
second make the argument like he's not a
pro wrestler I mean he is but the guy's
a Division one national champion
wrestler I'm like that's who I trained
for and trained to fight a Progresso I
dream to fight this guy and so uh I was
uh that was my gosh
[__] yeah it was huge like so many lots
who had never been interested in MMA all
of a sudden were like wantin to know
everything about it and because they'd
seen such an amazing fight like I I'll
be honest I think a lot of people hadn't
really heard of it before that it wasn't
very well marketed like WWE was full of
marketing it was all marketed to us
I mean people I'm Eli peep no more guy
who want us yet sooner I just sort of
like like the idea of Fighting's not I
mean and then suddenly opens people's
eyes up to and they're like [__] there's
like a pro wrestler now is gonna go and
try this out and suddenly everyone's
interested because you know you you know
you you're built like rock Omega you
know you're stronger than most of these
guys and that is something learning
about that from the outside you like
[__] we're going to see it was real
tutorial like it was like it was like
wrestling the real I don't know why our
[__] this is like actually got some
gravitas to it yeah how did it feel to
be part of that like you and did what
was your feeling towards him in towards
that fight there is no foul no I mean I
have no affiliates whatsoever the first
time and then even leave it up to the
second fight a lot of it was just
bravado or just you know what Connor
does to so lightly uh it wasn't until
after the second fight that actually I
had some animosity towards him for
because to me it was like once the fight
was over with the fights done yeah and
then you know he was still you know
going off and jumping around and he lost
a lot of respect from a lot of people
for what he did pause fight it because
that very rarely if ever I don't think
that's ever happened before
I mean maybe Rhonda a little bit when
she didn't share comes
but even Rhonda didn't start like
mouthing off and screaming like you're
not sure what was your experience what
was your experience backs up see you
know you're the focus of his anger um I
was surprised because at that point it
had been an act yeah on my part and then
when I'm looking at him I'm like wait a
minute
you were you acting are you serious that
must be can you imagine from here I mean
I know not fighters don't tend to
empathize with the other fighter but
from his perspective there must be
something incredibly frustrating about
fighting you twice and you just being
able to be like I was cool it's over now
but he's been beaten twice
Ravi Reynolds oh yeah you know what I
mean that like he's essentially he lost
emotionally emotionally love now he's
lost in the end and in the end he's that
guy who like he's the loser now do you
know what I mean huh yeah I don't know
if he's even has the intelligence to
understand that contract interesting
okay so you still like to wind him up a
little bit okay well I'm just being
truthful now okay um you know you know
Brock is not actually on come on he's
not the sharpest tool Nia okay yeah
toolbox forever and raw and so on that
was the Renaissance like for me that
that was Paul's motorcycle accident the
first fight was like the comeback of
from me I like where you really short
everyone off so got it how long does
that take Oh about two years yeah I mean
you went on a hell of a run as well
around that time you were one of the
fighters who evolved your skills along
the way like when we see in you fight
Nogueira
you stand up and come on massively from
just being a jujitsu file initially a
little bit like I will salt you a bit
like a heavyweight BJ Penn yeah because
you could do it you could do it all over
jinan I mean and I like that and he was
a crack player back in the day but was
the one pinpoint moment where you look
back and think this was what made me
evolve as a fighter
is there any moment where you looked at
it and thought you know are all kinds of
things and that's why I really don't
take it it was again it's not any movie
moments words I got this
every day in the gym when you go to
train there's sometimes small little
incremental changes and there sometimes
are big ones I think it's the same with
anybody when they're when they're
talking you have a conversation on an
idea that you have a certain stance on
and a conversation with somebody could
make a slight variation in that stance
that you have a okay with that
information I'm over here then you have
those big breakthrough moments where
someone says something to you read
something or your witness to something
that has huge rotation on how you think
about something right now it all [__]
this whole time of thought this way now
I'm over here so you have big moments
little moments but they're always
consistent you're always growing when
you when you fall Chet Congo and you
just wrecked him so easily and you
basically you became a killer be killed
style fighter actually it's so many
first-round finishes just breaking
people's arms taking the chins off was
there do you have a regret billion that
came to fight away you know people when
people watch frankly I fight nothing
will because it's kill or be killed and
you know by the sod but you can also die
by the sword
do you ever wish you'd be in a bit more
of a like some of the guys go for
decisions and they try and play it safe
urban love well I think that fighting is
in essence supposed to be that means
you're going for and open up your
options and looking to try to defeat the
person in front of you I'm trying to
play back and just go for the rules of
the sport you know hold someone against
the cage just to try to pull a decision
that's now why first a fight in the
first part I like martial arts because
one it's very difficult and it helps me
learn about myself and primarily I mean
when you're a little kid you go to the
park somebody else pushes you around but
can you say something back can you stand
up for what you believe in and you know
I've always had you know thoughts to
myself about situations and you can't
even stand up for your own principles if
you can't fight first right when people
talk about well violence is bad no it's
not it's very human what is so what do
you think I mean I know you have to make
another do some of that but what do you
say to those people email me doctor
they can fact themselves about that
somebody's weaker than you because of
you and I thought there's only one
outcome for that but I might still
believe that my ideas not you know a
doesn't make right
but still you should not just Equus as
to I'm going to be defeated but you know
to me it was being able to train enough
to make yourself as strong as possible
so that way you were in a better
situation to protect yourself now and
also to our society you know with tribal
animals so you might not be able to
defend yourself but then we're friends I
can defend you but at the same time I
think with sorry
the same time maybe I don't understand
how something works around my house you
walk in ago I understand that like boom
you're helping so then we can become
mutual contributors hello yeah okay and
so I'm acting that's important so I
think the people that are capable of
being strong warriors kind of have an
obligation to do so so would you because
the way you speak about it it sounds
like a sort of a very well thought-out
spiritual approach to something we do
describe yourself as a spiritual kind of
guy or is this I mean I don't know that
that's what people want to or to give it
as a definition but uh I guess they just
really try to be a scientist I really
try to look at what the the betterment
of you know me as an individual and then
as humans as a collective even morality
I think morality can be really you know
when people tell me like well you know
you're not very religious I'm like no
like well where do you get your morals
from them like you meanwhile rape murder
and kill you ya know because it's wrong
yes because there's a tribal entity part
of the tribe if I started raping killing
and murdering the rest of the guys in
the tribe would be like [__] this guy
yeah and eventually I have to go to
sleep
prevention is more of you than there are
of me and it wouldn't be very good to my
personal survival and then if I don't
survive how to my offspring survive so
it'd probably be best to work along with
everybody else
so even in a wolves or sympathies and
groups they have a certain moral code of
ethics because it's what contributes to
them being able to succeed as a group as
a pack and so on so and I say so why
don't you do anything else a so you only
know God this an animal so
so an imaginary friend of yours talks to
you told you that you can't rape murder
kill me among what happens if he told
you to do so would you do it well you
know I'm like whoa and I'm the crazy one
yeah we can be allies because I just
said what I thought you know you have
got a very scientific approach to a
methodical I think well yeah yeah I
thought I'm remainders of there's a guy
called Orion it is a body play I'm not
doing and why not personal yeah but he
he wrote everything down and he speaks
about weightlifting and training to be
the best version of you because that is
bodybuilding us yeah very similar the
way you speak did you have a write stuff
down macho was all mendel when you in my
head yeah it was conflict sitting there
and looking at things in you and then I
once again either I run into an obstacle
and I identified [__] I'm having a hard
time innocence or somebody else point
something out in me that I don't like
well you know look what you did right
there and I'm like I Anna was kind of
[__] up on listening to the criticisms
from others and then then trying to
figure it out and then up on that
breaking it down you know whether it's a
fight move where it's a personality
trait whether it's something I said like
even them sometimes in my speech what
did I say the other day Oh send the edge
of city recently I made a joke and
theories how the sharpest tool in the
box right now I it's not right Frank
like what so it's the sharpest knife in
the drawer
sure and I'm like oh [__] you're right I
mess it up and I think I did it earlier
today again yeah but I mean but so you
can look he'll come with a tool that
would be my point yeah but so my point
is I'm always looking to make bit of a
better person with urine analyzer of
situations and I guess that's probably
why you've naturally went into
broadcasting now you're a commentator
yeah we had done Hardy on who's
obviously getting to commentate and then
he said commentating has made him a
better fighter and he's excited to come
back because he feels like he's now much
better of breaking people down without
being emotionally attached the
disappointment he's now thinking of them
just as so as a fighter do you feel it
when you come back I mean I know yeah
you've done commentary for years but
you're really doing a lot of it at the
moment
if yeah I think that me breaking down
fighting and understanding the mortgage
of Saturn watched it I've simplified it
where certain moves are alright if you
put your hips here they win 80% of the
time if you put your hips here they win
it the other guy wins out and so I've
really simplified a lot of the fighting
in my head and go wow this is actually a
lot more basic than people want to think
of that they want to complicate
everything
and I think that you know if you truly
understand something the more simple it
actually becomes I think the biggest
obstacle I'm going to have coming back
in April is that 38 years old um I don't
have I have a very strong weakness for
food I like to eat whatever I want to
eat I travel a lot so my diet is crazy
when I'm home I like to drink beer so
now it's fantastic
basically yeah you're describing is I
get like four years of I live again so
now I have to start making these um
concession bill how bad do I want to
come back and fight right - how bad do I
want to be miserable and train hard and
do all the non mental aspects of it but
the physical part of fighting to give my
body back in shape and going back into
the gym and training is I like to Train
I like to be in the gym but I'm kind of
like an offseason bodybuilder there's a
offseason bodybuilding is fun right
it really is yeah you go lifted a skinny
up body but like how's the offseason
great yeah the heat would they want
their lifted heavy they feel good the
guy 12 weeks before competitions do you
like being a bodybuilder
[__] this [__] right I've never met a
bodybuilder - it's for competition it's
happy that he's a bodybuilder right it
is the same thing as being a fighter
offseason is fun you know
when I'm not training for a fight
fighting and training it can be a lot of
you know I enjoy it right now and the
back of my head oh my god I can do this
together like yeah I'm fooling myself
right now I got to prepare myself
mentally that when it gets time to get
ready to fighting again then because I'm
so far out of shape when I was started
forward to back um
the training for that and then the diet
behind that over the last couple of
years I've struggled with because you
know
[__] man I do do that I don't want to
man I just got there is there is good
things about being a heavy weights
especially as you getting older because
we're seeing the heavy weights last the
longest by a country mile yeah we're
seeing I think more more contact is he
mid forties have 43 80s element that
powered the last thing legal so you know
me need certainly had a lot of that last
time before I yeah I personally think
you'll do good as long and I just want
to make sure that I'm honest with myself
here you know people ask about
retirement stuff um general number of
fights in your head no I just want to go
until I can no longer perform at a high
level if I go out there and it looks
embarrassing you know I just have to be
honest with myself in the critics and go
yeah you know right now I'm just kind of
wasting everybody's time no it sounds a
lot like you are you're very good at
being your own psychologist your own
sports psychologist a lot of the way you
speak sounds similar to other sports men
who have their own guy who helps them
sort their own head out do you think
you're quite self-sufficient and with
that I think I'm open minded to take
advice where I can I like to read it all
and AH and study things and also too I
listen to people you know I've actually
similar successful I hear them talk and
they'll say something I tried to break
it down on well you know what are they
trying to say is that something I can
work and I really think I'm that's
really just part of life again
constantly learning from your
environment how to take those tools in
and make yourself a better person to
enjoy watching fighting because you
think you enjoy fighting but if that two
different things up it's funny that's
why right now kind of I'm trying to do
commentary for them but one of the
reasons why I love the ACV is that there
is no Conor McGregor okay we don't have
to really sell a fight that was always
my least favorite part of fighting was
sitting down in the room to do a uh you
know interview of a guy what do you
think the guy you're fighting like well
you know he's good at this is good at
that I map I go here the like
man that's not going to sell tickets
yeah you know I my god [__] and so then
a couple of times I remember I used to
frustrate the hell out of the people but
tell me what you want me to say man well
we don't really want to put words in
your mouth Amal yes you do yeah you just
want me to make believe in my head that
I came upon them myself but every time
I'm telling you what words I want to say
you're saying that I'm too nice that I'm
being too laid-back that it's boring I
hear you
I'm okay with this but because I'm not
naturally very good I'm a good smartass
I really am I really being a smartass
being snarky Lawrence could relate a lot
that I'm good at but straight up just
saying this guy sucks and I'm gonna come
in there and I'm gonna crush your face
in I would never say that real like ya
mean it just not me it's not my
personality I might be like hey buddy
nice shoes no three other ladies usually
you must have no friends they let you
come out with those things yeah oh Jesus
you're like are you trying me where you
have no condoms without your birth
control yeah ha ha you know so that I
could be funny in a dick but as far as
straight-up just like you know I was
never mean well and so I was struggled
with that so now with the ACV you know
guys come out in there's a little bit of
marketing but for the most part it's
fight alright get out of here next fight
go no ring card girls even which might
not be the best part look at me a little
concessions made but it won't tell me we
can definitely so fixed out of cockles
yeah
but uh but you know but for the most
part uh you know it's fight after fight
after fight up to find out to fight I
don't have to hear the guy talk after
sly about who he wants to fight next you
know very rarely they'll give the
microphone to somebody so they can think
craboo knacks alright the next fight the
backstage waiting to go as soon as this
fight ends next one the next ones coming
so sometimes I mean one time we were
here in Manchester we have 26 fights in
the car same show or the same distance
to does it the regular format for the
UFC and Bellator and all them have you
know we can do twice as many fights so
if you like fighting you can see twice
as many in a circle so now
you guys are screwing me over because of
the film bullfighting podcast I have to
watch the fight so I know what I'm
talking about so I'm sitting there and
now I don't want to go I have not
watched a fight live in a year laughs
not seen one live so sometimes I do miss
some things I go hey what did you think
about when Joe or or Brian said this and
like I have no [__] clue what you're
talking about because I put the fight on
I fast forward as soon as that I see the
referee do that boom okay play all right
sometimes I listen to the in-between one
minute but soon as that fight me as soon
as the fight is over with I'm
fast-forwarding it so I mean boom I see
one guy's hand raised real quick the
other in the next fight go alright go
boom go I want to see the fight yeah I
would and then sometimes through social
media or to Richard goes hey after the
fact this guy said this or art should
rewind it
okay alright what are you saying I have
to watch now yeah and you have to find
that bravado style of things but then I
guess it's oh the ACB makes you
appreciate the other way of doing it
which is you got your photo just put
them without you have seen maybe you
wouldn't appreciate ACB in the same way
like those other Klein and now like I
said I get to see what I like the most
yes um you know there's probably a
reason why I've never been a huge fan of
Pro Wrestling I know who the pro
wrestlers are but I have never my entire
lifetime sat down and watched a Royal
Rumble chill I have no idea
right I've seen glimpses of it too risky
in highlights I've never bought one
never watched it okay I think the actual
aspect of what they're doing is pretty
cool the stunts of the radio but
actually getting into okay this guy to
the middle person is promos and it's
it's all about these on the microphone
is more of the Rope McGregor does like
outside of the Ring the so father yeah I
don't watch soap operas yeah so when I
see people that are into that like Conor
McGregor right I get it
and more power to them for being such a
great able to understand what people
want but people want soap operas yeah I
don't watch soap operas you have a lot
of energy of those two people hate each
other rather than these are two athletes
who've trained for the last 15 years
they're going to go in there put our
skills to the test and see which guy's
the best fighter they don't want that
they want bad luck when I want you
excites I'm saying bolt lineup I knew
that the guy from it was a Dyson gassing
from America his timeless is for those
Wayne assisted in this guy's time is
this I really did need them to talk to
each other I really wanted to see
well [__] let's see you know how fast
give him same do this you know is he
gonna break his record this time I'm
just watching the sport eat of it I
don't care if Hussein you know what he
says to the other guy it's like well he
said this before him like even they were
doing a little bit with the Michael
Phelps with the one African swimmer
right yeah and I got a staring at each
other like really who gives a [__] all
you had to do is tell me that guy beat
him last time so it kept him from
getting a gold medal I'm like okay
that's cool alright now I'm interested
now see how the scaligeri I think I'm
certainly not to marketing though
because you know you do like there's
certain cycle American sports prove that
don't they like general certain certain
people certain sports that are marketing
numbers and other sports better
marketing numbers I think it's just how
you set them people like soap operas
generally I just I'm happy to not be a
fan of it myself so I think excuse me
I'm not really being good at it do you
enjoy watching other sports then can
you're saying you're watching years ago
the Lakers yeah I I do I just don't get
heavily into them because you know I got
away from kids and I already spent so
much my time in a gym then when I come
home to tell hey you know I'm going to
put the game on
I can watch certain games at certain
times it becomes acceptable I'd have to
read them the wife I got a look at her
I'm gonna watch the game no I'm not
going to watch the game right yeah I've
done that so it sounds like okay I'm
gonna go over here and do this she's all
really I'm oh no no go ahead do it among
that is a [__] trap yeah the wife
just got an entire em I know
Yaman got me yeah what is what is the
front me other God like what woody cuz I
know you got three kids you got a older
girl who's in a teenage year two young
boys what are you like as it does how'd
you feel oh I'm actually pretty I loved
being a father I think that's one of
most important things that I could do
now is because our fathered children and
I think I have an obligation I know I
have an obligation to give them the best
opportunity to be successful you know
individuals and be a part of society I
think of more of us as men fought that
way we would be better as a whole
extremes will take care of your yard and
the whole neighborhood's gonna look nice
yeah very mean experience how many men
don't have that in the brain or like
their I've met a lot of men who've got
kids to so many different women like I
mean obviously sometimes you know you
think you're in the right relationship
and sometimes you'll end up in another
relationship and you may have to two
girls with kids here like things like
that happen sometimes but when you meet
dudes who've got like four girls
different kids and they like and they
tie it all this has is [__] clean and
up your ass here that's how I think of
it you're a peasant you are you
daughter's greeting into the working
class as far as manual labor they're the
chances of your children or you have in
any type of success you're okay with
mediocracy whereas I think more like a
king I want I'm going to make sure that
my children my unit is as strong as
possible so that way when they go off to
have spouses and we all come over there
is high ranking as they can be so they
can find another highly evaluated human
being to make sure that they breed on to
make better people and now look I'm
creating a kingdom so how do you have a
kingdom when you have four or five
different wives or women then you have
three or four the king and really is
tried and it didn't work it's really
gonna destroy stuff you know I mean it's
really Kate of yeah like that that
perspective is that they they want to be
able to [__] around do whatever they
want to do and that's where they get the
values but I think a lot of people that
sort of runs out for a lot of people do
you like what you're talking about is
the longevity of a relationship and
those guys don't tend to have raised to
be fair getting into the UFC young man
that you were meeting meeting the girl
who you're going to marry then a lot of
blogs would have struggle with that
because with the UFC it would be in a
fighter and being a big dude you're
going to get a lot of attention hmm did
you ever find that challenging oh yeah
of course as a man and that is a
challenge but instead look at the things
that I knew that from the number-9 met
my wife in fact here's a little intro
into our relationship when we first
started dating she moved in with me
she knew quick none are we dated
probably for about that
six months okay no and then she may
eight months she moved in with me and um
at that point I made sure that you know
I told her said all you know a bank
account anymore you don't have to work
anymore I'll take care of you and then
she was like I don't know you know that
seemed like a great idea
so I grabbed a birth control I hid them
so I purposely impregnated her you know
so it's really funny like I'm never
doing it for thousands of you I love the
way the other way around I purposefully
did you tell that absolutely pregnant ya
know and she's like I got pregnant you
know I remember first I know I wasn't
ready for it like even though like this
is my intentions you know to me like you
know it's just like I you know wouldn't
we got the call and I took it to a
hospital now like oh she's pregnant I'm
like okay this is happening yeah um I
waited a couple months and then I let
her know that like you know I kind of
she was you know your birth-control
missing for a couple days I'm like I
knew that if I threw it off rhythm a
little while
that you know that clapping he throw
around Cuba Davis he made it sound okay
with you look funny even with a last
child that was all me
right our youngest again giro Rob
Nielsen blood Ronin she was like look
you know my wife's five years older than
I am so she's like look you know you
know uh cage at the time was you know
three years old it was just getting out
of diapers you know now there are you
know when I was change diapers anymore
oh my god if you feeling like you didn't
relax at this point right called wick
stone chill and [__] me I mean she's
doing all the hard work you know taking
care of is little time I'm at the gym
training coming back but I was like we
gotta just try for one more and I mean
I'm sure enough she didn't want to so at
the time you know our birth control
method was uh it was pretty relied upon
me yeah so I just made sure that uh we
slipped up yeah we actually pretty easy
to show that we slip yeah yeah which is
funny cuz then when she got pregnant her
mother was just like you know cuz you
know when we found out it was funny I
was with some other fighters retraining
and there
staying with me so we stopped by she's
like you know I miss my period it's just
like did you know you were safety of the
night you're like oh yeah so I'm like I
don't she's I've missed okay for two
weeks a night so we stopped at a
Walgreens she goes in and buys the birth
- trip she runs off to the bathroom and
I bought I remember chocolate milk you
know people talk about I'm drinking the
girls were sanitizing I'm obese pregnant
is a really a good thing that's a big so
then here comes my wife out of the
bathroom issues doing everything right
Oh balls
yeah I pregnant um oh yes another lady's
looking at me like this is like you know
a set of what's going on here you know
and so we go out to the car and I'm in a
good mood but I know I can't talk about
it because you know so she walked up she
gets in the driver's seat I get the
pastor see now the two guys in the
closet show us walk in he they don't
know why and she comes out bawling and
I'm like ha ha so we get their hero
folks gifts he runs upstairs she shuts
the door so I'm sitting and they run
into the guest room and they come back
and they're their other bags like hey
Matt we don't know what's going on we'll
get out anyway no it's okay like she's
pregnant it's like is that good well ya
know the chocolate milk I'll just give
it a couple days you have get over it
yeah how old a young young it no he's
eight a clamp okay she got her vengeance
on me uh what was it
oh [__] five years ago when he was three
so okay we're from really done like yeah
we're really done you know really yeah
I'm like but then I [__] myself was
like well the boys have brothers the
girl has no sinner to this day yeah so I
know
come on good so they're not so then
she's like all right tomorrow you have
an appointment docking ago she goes if
you love me and you want this reaction
to work you have to go get a vasectomy
ah yeah so I got cut the slip met I mean
to be fair you did everything you could
up until that point yeah yeah what what
it actually does that until they're
getting nothing I wash on Instagram the
other day that's like everything it's a
little difficult because you have to sit
up on the bench and you put your leg up
in stirrups and I've never in my life
ever had to do
you only have reinforcement so this big
after no so I'm sitting there it's funny
because I walked in there the guy calls
me by my real name
you know it's medical paper but my name
is Francisco and so the guy goes I'm
Francisco Santo smeared see right yeah
so I'm like alright cool this
[__] does not know who I am yeah
because you'll make this less awkward
because okay well everything's up at the
bar then I'll see you later today at 3
o'clock you know your seizure me right
cool so then I leave and then I ask him
okay it didn't be able to be in the room
with the ceiling because I you know I
feel of the nurses and stuff you learn
I'll just be honest all right all right
cool yeah so walk out so I come back at
3 o'clock I go in the room ok disrobe
from your waist down okay like all you
know you know you should have you know
use a razor blade to share my ride you
know
no problem nurse or myself [__] oh can I
like that I just lay there so you have
to lay there no you know a feeling right
and it's also a young nurse ceará me not
that she was a can but yeah she's still
young cute girl I'm sooner I get all
this is weird like I hope I don't you
know it's very awkward so the guys you
want to get pregnant that's wrong with
me I machine before I always make jokes
that I have a movie set gun oh my god
make all the noises looks real with no
bullet you know so I'm sitting at
another guy let's just be the guys
sitting in a stool and here my you know
I'm here you know and he keeps telling
me hey keep your legs spread because
it's just natural that I keep wanting to
pull my legs in so I'm like fighting
them back and I'm like trying to read
the different [__] in the room and also
doc scoliosis you I never realize here
so he's about a minute into it they give
you an injection de nom you and you
don't say do you feel this and like no I
die I can feel pressure but doesn't hurt
okay so hey so Frank you never thought
of getting into movies really like a
really good understand all buddy knows
what but didn't have the conversation
with me like with my balls right here at
there so first I was like really awkward
and then by the way the nurses in the
rooms are still seen leave yeah yeah is
I you can't diploma well I hope you have
a fault but get in the mood
well nor they kept me somewhat like I'm
sitting there to getting solving
problems like Bob so embarrassed right
now no I'm like wait a minute
how many balls is this guy seen in there
and you don't give a [__] he's just
talking to me I'm like I don't give a
[__] about me it's like getting in the
kitch like to be a dentist you're like
it's like how many mouths is this guys
yeah so that's and for him yeah that's
like an everyday procedure over there he
must realize that from that's pretty
[__] huge for most guys you know oh
yeah some you have you've got three kids
so it's actually you get out a very good
procedure is huge the paviva is pretty
fun of correctly yeah yeah because some
people will yeah the comments comments
we've got we've got loads of questions
for as well as I'll crack on with some
of those you the Twitter will hustle and
we've got to cook the questions quite a
lot actually do you have a big regret in
your career of life
yeah don't train through injuries hmm
far too many times work you know there's
this need I think an MMA to prove or in
sporting it's in general that I know if
you have a busted ankle just wrap it up
and get to practice whereas now I know
no practice is over with or do something
different in practice that'll still make
you a better athlete and prove that
micro percentage and let's address your
ankle because you're probably going to
win or lose fights more or less based
off of how injured you are more so than
anything else whatever may is one of the
worst sports if not they will support
for injuries I guess there's so Ted do
you have days where you wish you take in
an easier life maybe a different job all
the time not so much because it's hard
but then sometimes I think about my
contribution to society at the end of
the day I fought people you know and I
fight people I'm an entertainer when you
really think about that's exactly what
you although a dope yeah that kind of
bugs me you don't feel like you're taken
seriously enough blow it with what did I
really do for anybody I'm not a doctor
I'm not a police officer not firefighter
then you've just said before you all
having children who who might be that
given them the education and that you've
actually only thing keeps my sanity and
one of the main reasons why I do my
podcast from
fighting is if I can share my ideas on
martial arts martial arts should be
something you do besides your job as a
hobby or like kind of going to church on
Sunday I became the priest I made the
church my whole job my whole existence
um and so uh you know not very good
balance in life but it is the road I
took and I got to start over I
definitely would have won and go in the
medical field you know maybe become a
doctor you know something where I could
have used my mind of problem-solving
skills and a much more helpful way for
society
so sometimes at the end of the day you
are off keys or I make fun of a kibosh
Ian Wright then I'm like I'll sit there
and go I got kind of shut my mouth cuz
I'm really not any better yeah oh yeah
ego Bennett it's only the real ass is
pretty much be realistic now you I mean
I Seeley Sam but you'd also say there's
going to be a lot of feelings when we go
get a proper job like we go like
youtubers get get a proper job sort of
thing you like info like my arguments
that is like like you say there's got to
be balanced in order to have a
functioning society people have to be
motivated and entertained and you've got
to have that relaxation time and I get
it maybe society being structured
different in a way so we didn't have TVs
and entertainment and you might not have
to be in everyone clear in Timm selves
but you know if you are moping a p40
doctor yeah and that's where I do gain
satisfaction now with my existence is
that not only do I help use the things
that I trained and I had people's
attention through what I done as a
fighter that now maybe if I could give
advice or any kind of direction or spark
like like I think sometimes people think
of like well I know how to do it I'm
like I don't really think that's what a
leader does so yes because we're
valuable um I'm still human
yeah you can name the greatest human
being in the world and I'll show you
flaws yes I'll show you somebody who has
probably things that they don't want to
talk about publicly
um Martin Luther King I mean he was a
great man in our society there were some
things about his marriage that you know
and some extracurricular activity that
he had outside his marriage that is not
you know Muhammad Ali
Jay
Carrie was Marilyn Monroe I mean like
you know you have guys that are great
human beings are not taking anything
away from them but if you make yourself
out to be something more than that than
a human being I think that's when people
could distort your message like well he
was that great there's no but I did
something great at this one moment and
if it helps you spur you off into your
own direction and take advantage of it
use it as a vehicle for your own mind
you don't have to just sit and go I want
to be like him
mmm that's scary that's don't be like
somebody but learn from their path and
then try to take your luster dust but
like what they inspired us about isn't
it's about taken from them and put using
it through what you're capable of but if
you create a hero sometimes a hero
worship that isn't I'm scares me because
it's like you might get disappointed
it's that classic Batman line like you
either die a superhero you live long
enough to see yourself become the
villain like people get disappointed but
it's like I'm a germs like I've been in
many Jews before we've grown and seen
Lao Tzu or convinced they're going to be
the next big thing you know and you look
at them fight you think you're buggers
ship of chinna them in and you have to
be honestly yourself like you but some
of them are so convinced with a pilot
hero-worship that I'm following in the
footsteps I'm the next McGregor and
sometimes they don't get that shot
because that's that must be hard because
actually you some of those guys are also
completely limited by the fact they've
only really got that gym like that maybe
there's no one in there look at the
relative idiom that's tricky yeah it is
that must be tricky though when you when
you think about retiring your identity
it like how much of your identity is
tied up and being a fighter you know
nothing was huge but I've already made
that transition that I know that my
father because that I am a human being
that has other attributes that I'm to
contribute to besides just fight now
there's going to be you having that's
very clear though but with some fighters
it's equally clear that this is all they
have and then that's why I say I don't
know like Ricky Hutton and some players
they go off the deep end after they
leave fighting because what the [__] do
I do now to achieve that buzz of getting
in the ring I think it's very much of a
a narcissistic point of view that I have
this line like now I can't
go that's how life is even life itself
he's only going to have it for the blink
of a fraction of a moment and all the
universe of billions of years of the
world and the universe has been around
we're gonna have a blink of life and
it's over with so you have a blink of
Fame I think you have to be okay with
the fact you transition that you no
longer going to be you know I mean it's
like the girls I see them I'm so
appreciative that I notice about my wife
my wife is still a very attractive woman
but she's in her 40s she's very
attractive for 40 or you know she
doesn't leave me look at it she looks
younger than her age she dresses classy
and nice I've seen some of other girls
around her age they're still dressed
like a girl who's in their 20s chill and
it's painful to look at I just go hey
you don't mean like you know 25 year old
could wear that you're not a 25 year old
show please stop very mad it sounds a
lot like that we've said this very often
in this podcast some people don't
fulfill that part of their life and then
they just continue that part of their
life until that like an effort easy
sounds a lot like you're someone who
completes tasks get through things and
your wife's very similar and if you can
just complete those parts of life and
compartmentalize and back you tend to be
able to move forward and just take it
for what it is like even now my fighting
career I'll come back when I'm here in
April and fight I don't have the same
reason that when the fight that I fought
laughter I really wanted to try to fight
back you know you always go for a title
ask me if I want to fight for title yeah
I really don't I realized that I'm older
now I'm farther along in my career but
you know what now I just want to find
other big fights you know maybe some
with Bellator and fight fade or you know
something like that would be something
to do you know one fight so I thought
like the people would be really
interested in right it's like look I
don't want to fight the nuts pop two or
three guy it's probably to keep my ass
anyway
I have to acknowledge that that's just
how it is how am I supposed to keep up
with a guy who trains every day
doesn't have to worry about his wife and
kids or doesn't have them and now he's
28 years old and now to go go kick that
guy's ass him I remember the whole
percentage argument I had with you the
percentages are not on my side then I'm
okay with understanding
that realistic like you are such a
truthful person and you you've got no
problem clearly and being honest with
yourself do you think when you lose
fights and I will talk about this at Dan
Hardy he said he in a way you got a bit
of there was some good that came out of
losing because he was clear he wasn't
clouded and thinking the alpha-male way
of thinking if I'm going to knock
everyone out I'm going to be everyone
once you have that awakening of all I am
be able and I'm just I am a man
generally I think that can be a good
thing in a way I think it's excellent
things I think any time you can be raw
and realistic I think that our people
appreciate it it's like having a
near-death experience someone finds out
all you have cancer and then you find
out maybe you don't that could be a
blessing right because sometimes we have
this way we as human beings we're able
to [__] in hide things that scare us
so we tell that can happen so the idea
like well I'm not gonna die anytime soon
so you don't really know that you could
be done tomorrow you could die tonight
and that heart just stops pumping you
know who knows and so then it's like oh
how did you treat your wife before you
left or what did you was laughing you
said to your children so when I walk
around I get my wife's like you know
Jesus Christ Frank you know come on
right I'm like well you know maybe
you're so exceed tomorrow and I don't
say he'll all the time
hopefully she's like stop talking like
that I'm like I might look like that
maybe well maybe won't see it that's
like well I really hope so yeah it does
one thing that sort of occurred to me
you broke it you broken people's arms in
their careers how do you feel about that
because you know what we know is their
fault
yeah like is that how you deal give it
up well I mean I'm just being truthful
with it too yeah
and but they've always had the
opportunities to tap the brakes it's
like it'd be like me tackling you in to
get in a football game with a legal move
you fall down you get a concussion yeah
so you don't feel it I'm not saying you
should but you don't feel a sense of
responsibility for that oh yeah you know
fighting works all right yeah it'd be
the equivalent of me um
you know if you go and you know you kick
above your head and you try to do like
what they call like the bicycle kick
right say and you land and break your
clavicle yeah I'm trying to score on me
is it my fault should I have stepped out
of the way so you can score so you
didn't have to try to fix that way no I
guess I guess my thought was more like
as a fighter yourself you know what it's
like to be defeated do you ever see
those guys afterwards and talk to them
or like what was it like or gmod here I
should have maybe let them off the hook
in there I feel bad that yeah that
what's your relationship like with him
like will you see them up to it in a
like [__] man you broke my arm or like
you know don't actually the first guy's
arm I broke really badly Tim Sylvia the
perp Layton is on it was uh you know
coming month later the weather chilly we
were not at some fights in Jersey and we
went out to a bar afterwards and he was
hitting on these girls they were talking
them and he's showing them a scar and
yeah that's the [__] did it to
me you know like you know so yeah you
just doesn't mud this yes these two in
the ball a rookie [__] yeah
I sort of a weight chat supply he's
right wingman yeah like yeah I broke him
but he's a great guy going but he didn't
tap man yeah you wanted to keep flames
yes oh yeah did me uh all right another
one have you got an advice for your 20
year old self if you could I think it
was Prior goes back to that regret thing
yeah yeah just make sure that you know
there's no there's no sense of
accomplishment behind fighting through
pain or injury in a gym it doesn't prove
anything if anything it just causes you
to be less of a man later on because in
your scar tissue and injuries and you
know why would you do that in a sport
were millions of dollars on the line you
would never let during practice your
star striker is me might be pop I'll
just wrap it up finished practice yeah
they're pulling this and saying they
would pull them off the pitch though
your vitals or MMA isn't really there in
some of the sports as well I don't think
even I mean no sports make enough money
there's other people around it here that
you save the athlete from himself that's
what's funny isn't it is like it's only
as soon as that value as the athlete has
monetary value to someone that they
start to wrap them up whereas actually
like your value is more than just
monetarily to someone else you got your
own body that's what's crazy about it is
really you have more value monetarily
don't treat like that human people kind
of yeah yeah it's business why you
saying it who is the wildest MMA fighter
you've ever met is there someone who
stands that was just a crazy
son-of-a-bitch
a hardy is crazy and not in the way that
they probably mean where he just starts
talking about doing his like [__]
trips to Peru and Don Hall DS yeah yeah
yeah he's wild in a different way yeah
like in a good way but just kind of far
out spiritual yeah there's some times
we've had some conversations on this
plane right yeah but no but but
interesting guy and he lives by what he
says no yeah the other man you guys who
you just could not go to the ball with
her because they're just a liabilities
they're just half the guys to fight
hahaha a few stories okay
I don't go to bars a lot of fighters
because of everything yeah someone said
did any of the ring girls get chopped up
by the fighters how regular was that I
should have waited a bit yeah I am
really not responsible for any of that
not not front anyway yeah alright yeah
lots on the level of MMA outside the UFC
right now with the soon to be on the
upside massively massively on the uprise
I think the UFC right now with the new
ownership appears to be very profit
oriented and you know I think Lorenzo
and Frank when they had it very much a
passion for the sport I think you could
see that you know they trained in it
before they even owned the the USG and
so uh the new owners I've actually never
been on a mat they don't even know what
an armbar ever even Federer media
committee bits writer so that being said
it's a business venture and I think that
it's fans especially the hardcore
friends that are an MMA I think they
sent it because I can see and so on I
think that's an opportunity now for the
other developers the APB's very also
need to find everybody else to take
advantage of and start to a grow which
is good for us because the more
competition there is of having to put on
good shows the more you know it's like
any product itself if you only have one
company who makes cars if they make the
shittiest car in the world
gives a [__] you haven't you're going to
buy that car the only one in town also
in another dealership pop something's
like well we have a better car well even
now like you see with the uber and taxi
cab driver argument I'm like well you
know Bluebird provides a better service
completion cabs you need to pick up the
ship whereas before you wanted a man
before Hoover came up I've been in some
cabs that I probably wouldn't put an
enemy in I mean just stink horrific
piece of [__] I'm comfortable right it
doesn't give a [__] either you don't
like you and it makes it very apparent
at a racket in this basically it was a
racket you could go anywhere but now
it's like well I'm just gonna go ahead
and over this and if I go okay let's
start going back and forth where it is
that is interesting not yet that's it's
the same inviting that so now for the
fighters it'll be good because now it's
like well we're in the past you have
seen but I want to give you X amount of
money I don't want that we're gonna go
to yeah
we're now it's like well a CD or
Bellator now we're going to have people
arguing so quality of fighting you know
the money the fighters will make it go
up so I'm saying right before you make
that walk you're about a fight how are
you feeling because from what I've
remember someone once said about you an
interview that you are quite chilled out
before you go there is that true
yeah I'm nervous in the locker room when
I get all the music but it's funny it's
the walk makes me the most nervous
because it's a bunch of people and I
tell people that I'm like if I just told
you had to walk imagine the fight 10,000
people there I'm going to give you a
microphone you have to go up there and
recite a poem how [__] nervous is the
average person going to be we're gonna
come out we're going to scream for two
minutes clear the room okay say the poem
the only hitting you in the face
whole room is watching you makes you
don't stutter a word don't forget
something
there's gonna be a certain apprehension
that almost every human being has so
that means to walk out once we close the
cage door and I can look over and see
somebody that I've done a thousand times
walking in front of 10,000 people well
I've done it you know what
28 times down the UFC still not a ton of
practice yeah what's that what's it like
to look across
see that guy like a you have you ever
looked across until [__] that guy's big
all the time okay but then you just
clear up on the moment you know just but
I've done that thousands upon thousands
of thousands of times where I've been in
the gym training and the other guy we're
going to fight each other
so I'm looking across at you yeah you
know we talked of probability earlier on
was there ever a moment where you looked
across the cage and thought 100 percent
got this guy he's mine now and you were
right or then I even felt like that
never never ever felt like I'm gonna I
got this
um I mean we've seen that backfire on
people before the winner the one that
springs to mind for me is when Bisping
when the title offers Rockhold rockhole
just looked so confident relaxes where
he looked like his walk with the dog it
isn't a good mainstay to be are and he
got caught I mean I think of him in
business at ten times I bet I'm Rockhold
every time yeah I mean I just think that
was the fight that because of his you
know uh you know cockiness cars came to
get caught I think if they were to
rematch you know any you know I think
that uh you know Bisbing or losses all
right McGregor vs. Mayweather I know
you've mentioned before and your podcast
because of I do listen that you feel
like there's going to be a huge
discrepancy in ability you yourself were
one of the one of the best boxers in MMA
and heavyweight division what would how
did you feel you did when you sparred
against boxers and where do you how far
do you think you were from their level
high I mean I spiral guys at Marco hook
remains to learn quite a few times and
they're better at boxing than you are no
matter how good maybe that's their sport
that's all they have to practice um
there's no way that you know in a boxing
match right now mister I try to break
down to everybody Makana McGregor is the
least accomplished and probably the
least skilled boxer that Mayweather has
ever faced in 49 fights and he does well
maybe there's not anybody out level
since 2007 someone said oh well because
he also just you know very much a
defensive master
there we has a hard time with South paws
well Manny Pacquiao's a South bone and
he completely made him look silly so
silly that people thought I'll manage
and fight anymore
manny has fought since then it looks
very good there is a boy he comes after
me hit him them all if a turtle Gotti
was still alive and you told me there
was a fight between a taro Gotti and a
boxing match with Conor McGregor and you
said who's gonna win I'm like in three
rounds which hero God is going to
completely take his head off if Connor
can make it past the third round I would
be shocked a bit whoa really
you made it that far Wow good for you
moral victory got knocked on the fourth
though you know yeah and so a churro God
he fought me with her and Mayweather
stopped him didn't just beat him on
points and so you know I just I just
besides anybody telling me that well he
could catch him with a shot you're right
the last 49 guys have fought Mayweather
could catch him with a shot and if
Mayweather win or McGregor wins that's
the only way it could happen and it's
like well I could go right now and kick
a ball up Donna de whoever you guys as
best goalie is there's a chance that he
dives the wrong way and I put the ball
in the goal are you willing to bet on it
no coming personally having heard you
manifesto I bet on you today but I but
there's not a lot of other people you
wouldn't yeah I mean if I did it a
thousand times maybe one flips through
yeah so that's like the fight will you
know McGregor pawn he's not going to win
around and just come out there and hold
his own and the other thing to that is
just fighting wise uh you know
McGregor's jab is okay he doesn't throw
you know his hooks yeah he throws a
right uppercut off the lead side here's
his left can't set up Mayweather has
other tools with his jab and it's hook
then he I mean come on he's out jab
Canelo yeah beat up Canelo Canelo and
Mayweather McGregor you think McGregor
could last with Canelo I don't beat him
last I think the only thing that helps
McGregor in this fight to potentially
gain credit respect and come out looking
like a moral victory is the fact that
this stylistic much of is probably the
best for him out of the top level boxers
so like if you put McGregor in there
with triple G I think that would be a
real like
we have no funerals to none I mean it
would be awful whereas because of the
lack of power from me with a despite
massive skill discrepancy we may be able
to see McGregor show a bit of heart and
lust quite a long time the only way
McGregor makes its decision loss is if
Mayweather decides to let them because
even though Mayweather
you're right maybe power wise doesn't
knock him out in the first three rounds
but Conor naturally is not a aerobic
athlete he has very explosiveness but if
you watch the third round of the Nate
Diaz fight Nate Diaz had him gassed
I mean Connor was backtracking legs
locked running from Nate why Nate's
point and laughing in Connors like your
ad-libs volley problems might with the
difference of minutes per round that
might help father
oh geez in three minutes five minutes it
doesn't really matter I think he's gonna
get tired and I think in the fourth
fifth round he's going to hit the wall
and you know and then Mayweather when he
senses if Mayweather wants to take him
out sixth seventh eighth rounds you can
start doing this it may weather you know
I mean accumulation of punch it's an
interesting though because McGregor
definitely did combat in the new site to
be fair and it is a much bigger harder
in my opinion than me whether or not at
all
you'd say Mayweather's a hold up on each
other Nate Diaz but despite the heavy
weight there the wit difference well I
mean Nate is 155 pounds lighter nobody
but he's a he's a big 155 whereas
Mayweather
is a very small one technique explosion
speed I don't think Nate know I mean
right now be said hey let's put them
both on pads really who can generate the
most power
no way yeah that's fair enough so maybe
that yeah there's interesting I mean
it's also websites as well as a
difference so let's go help let's put it
this way it's it's not it's it's not a
real fight it's an exhibition fight no
and you know and really I didn't think
it would happen because I didn't think
that Dana and UFC would relinquish a lot
oh yeah and basically they did they
Showtime this is their fight with you
know with Mayweather um they on has been
rented I guess
yeah it's quite interesting though
because it because of the exhibition
nature of it that you wonder how
mentally both those fighters approach
that I don't know good question
I mean I'm not that yet because I'm yeah
I'm nautically turned on by but it
certainly bears in Canarias corner you
say he's got a short Gus tongue what the
way Mayweather seems to operate in a
boxer matches like a computer
he sort of downloads the data that he's
readin and then uses that to figure an
equation in order to beat you got the
longer yeah problem exactly the way you
operate yourself obviously took
different sports but you use as a same
sort of process to me it seems like the
longer you give me weather the easier a
finds the way to beat you Conor McGregor
hasn't at the biggest gas tank and I
know it is an amateur way of looking at
it in it's a massive risk but do you
think the best possible route for
McGregor is to go out and go leather and
try and go for it first round and just
throw every wild punch because make the
best thing was talking about this
recently and he said sometimes when I
fight someone who isn't as skilled as me
because they try things that I wouldn't
usually see when I'm fighting top level
kick boxers and boxers it sometimes
catches as off guard I'm not expecting
they're using an amateur may often
upstage a professional yeah do you think
that may be a better way I think it's
the best course was to then I used to
gives a little bit of a highlight reel
yeah yeah it's basically for Instagram
isn't it that's what we want we want a
night in where I'm 30 seconds yeah great
event of like to that [__] yeah
but yeah I'm starting to believe that
that is the best chance familiar I think
automatically I am but even the chance
of a punch being landed a lucky shot
goes up so you owe the school of thought
that he'll barely around a punch if for
as long until me whether the site by
it's over one thing I was quite
interested that you mentioned earlier
first of all you said and you're so
guiding your kitchen corner going back
to what you say Conor fought a high pace
fight the first time he fought mate when
I would you watch the time output right
he gasped he had to shoot on me because
he started getting worked and punched
now box to him by Nate Diaz so I mean we
can argue about who hits harder but
there's no stretch of the imagination
that you think that Nate can box
anywhere near the world that Mayweather
box not at all so in the first value so
that's why and then Conor said it so he
felt it he's our [__] his energy was
more efficient than iron but since that
fight if you watched Conor he's slowed
down drastically he goes way too
methodical going I realize now that I
get tired he walked out with the belief
that I'm going to walk through Nate Diaz
and he must have ly underestimated his
chin and actually when you watch about
that fight which I watch it a few times
McGregor has punching that years he was
really poor in that sight he was way off
on a lot of shots in the second fight he
was connecting a lot and very in a much
lower pain oh yeah he has a bunch of
power function so that's quite
interesting in itself because he
obviously I think part the reason people
get excited about this this fight is
because they've seen Conor McGregor an
adaptable fighters and you can learn new
skills and those sort of things in order
to beat Nate Diaz and like that the only
reason why this is an exciting fight is
that you have the greatest promoter that
ever lived and all of combat sports and
yeah Conor McGregor and that's actually
my point is that actually it's been
marketed that way yeah and it's all
marketing and honestly the fight goes
Mayweather wins or Conor Atlanta so
lucky shot there's no other way that
goes and as far as quality of boxing
match you're not going to see quality
fight um so it's a fight to yourself how
much do you think was inherent to your
fighting and how much of it do you think
you did you ever think I'm slow I've got
to work on that or like well I need to
be better aerobic Li and then work on
that or do you think you just level out
as a fighter and you realize I can't go
any quicker or I can't you know I'm weak
here I just have to embrace that well I
think it's a combination number two
there's always a little bit of
adjustment and always improvement you
can make in areas but a lot of things
are birthright like you know um some
guys you know their aerobic capacity
there's a limitation
just like there's a limitation to how
strong you can get now no matter how
hard you train you're probably never
gonna be stronger than Brian right
you'll see about that right I mean it
just adverse you guys had different
genetics yeah
and so people can see strength and power
sometimes they don't see aerobic
capacity
flexibility there's so many things that
are kind of a birthright not that you
can't improve them but you can't go like
120 pound weakling think you're going to
win the world Strongest Man competition
if you graduated high school at 120
pounds you're never going to win the
world Strongest Man he has a new person
question athletically speaking yummy
you've dealt with boxers and you are one
of the best athletes yourself in the
heavyweight division who do you think
the bow roughly is that of Mayweather
McGregor I really don't know that I
think I'm the pretty clothes for me I
think the Gregor's like I can't actually
imagine me with us swinging his legs
around and doing the kind of kicks that
yeah Gregor might be an overall better I
guess substituted to be 10 on the sport
I think that if we were to play soccer I
pick me with it because I knew that he
McGregor xyrix though but he can also
run for 90 minutes okay Berger here run
for 90 minutes
you think the age fight American that I
pally would pick Conor cause i'ma go
he's more explosive a little taller the
longer arms and which position he's
playing now inaudible quarterback yeah
I'd be interested see I mean since each
will play any impact at all on me
because you never got touched he's not a
mother Milo now so I don't think so
where do you play your American football
so you saying you played American
football in high school here do playing
weak and so what position do you play
when you miss defensive end and
linebacker of them I played fullback
okay interesting so and you never you
were never tempted to go down that route
well I was but then now we're talking
about how I have a very defiant
personality yeah yeah I came up on your
back right yep but you couldn't because
you built like I mean you know you built
like a good player you could you can
[__] some people up if you're in that
and you can make a lot more money that
way
I mean it's too late to go but no but no
I'm just sort of out enough here to try
to sell in the 'quran choice I can make
probably more money than 90% of the NFL
yeah I just there's obviously they're
breaking that top few percentage Tom
Brady's and stuff of the world deal yeah
make an ungodly amount of heavyweights
do well in the UFC by how about is the
average pay in the NFL's like 500 some
are thousands okay to realize that okay
fair enough
yeah not everybody is making not the
multi-millions but yeah I mean suppose
either way you're still making a very
reasonable thing to be an athlete yes
great this and that but then I'm going
to look cool can I just I just want the
words in my head you were talking about
making your kids interested or
transitioning your kids into fighting as
well and sort of how you refer your dad
yeah to learn new martial arts if
being a musician you can want your kids
studying music yeah doesn't mean you
want them to go ahead and quit high
school to join a band yeah so I don't
want my kids to fight professionally but
they are going to Train and have a
certain level of proficiency so that
they have all the things that it comes
with being a good martial artist and so
what's that like as a father obviously
you and you got off your dad and there's
a certain level of pleasure you you can
see when you talk about that is it sin
to use that yeah very much so because
I'm see that there's things to be gained
from being a good martial artist we're
aspiring that down that path that it
makes you a better person and do you
think your kids do you kids look up to
you as a fighter and do you think they
know about you as a fighter in all they
do I but I get uncomfortable too much
when we talk about it like my son plays
the video game yeah
there's a joke in my household if you
want Frank to leave the room turn the
video game on right boom I'm out why I
don't watch myself too much I don't like
it okay makes me uncomfortable to remain
like ah are there certain vanity to it
that I don't naturally have I don't
actually possess it's like an actor in a
movie Emily maybe I guess and so when I
see it it just makes me uncomfortable I
think you make us in everybody else like
oh this isn't real I mean I gotta go see
it also is sorry is there also an
element that like it's not really you
but it's like an image of you up on the
screen like II you know you you're not
that's not really you is still weird
yeah I don't know it makes you
uncomfortable yeah it's weird isn't it
and would you get pissed off if you saw
one of your kids fighting with you and
not doing the moves I supposed do you do
have you noticed a lot of similarities
between your kids and yourself like oh
yeah in martial arts particularly do you
ever see them do a movin thing he's got
it that's my kid he's got it yeah yeah
and then vice versa though I don't
really put that much pressure on them
because I see too many parents are try
to lift as if children without God is no
worse than those and so uh I don't need
my son or my daughter to do how I do
things are doing how you do it you know
so I guess it's also why I don't really
pick and push the like you know watch
this video look how I did this
no not at all pay their own pose now in
fact if anything only time I used to go
to my videos or if I go to my fights
it is usually always off of failure and
then I tell them how I was thinking
after the failure and what resolution I
came to afterwards I don't think I've
ever showed my children a successful
she Hey look at my arm Bart that guy I
was gonna say yeah what's there to learn
from that okay but I can teach them like
you see how he hit me this is what I did
wrong this is what I changed in practice
and then when I came back it didn't work
either because I assumed this this would
led me to that assumption this how I
came through this and now I can you know
Bob yeah that's what's quite interesting
because I was I was brought up in a
household and most people know some
comments anyway like where violence was
like that wasn't really a thing that's
in my family do you know what I mean so
it's like well don't watch any fighting
all together because we don't agree that
you know I mean and obviously since some
commands the word like things change but
like your approach is the complete
opposite of that which is which is
really interesting you're a wife or
you're just really yeah exactly like do
you you never felt on you never felt I'm
not saying you should feel uncomfortable
you never felt uncomfortable so with
your kids watching you in a fight it was
never anything so no because it's a it's
a sporting event that I select with
somebody else there's no hatred or utter
and I heard somebody would take anything
from them but I mean I'm very open and
realistic about what life is about just
because you don't want to talk about
with your children just cuz I don't put
the television on doesn't mean it
doesn't exist anymore
it doesn't mean when they go to school
they're not dealing with people that
also know that it exists how do you tell
them to deal with that that must be same
as a parent approaching that a battle
sort of your dad's a fighter or you know
like your dad we just you know every
time they have a problem that comes up
if I could they come home and you know
my biggest way as I put them to private
school that helps okay but you know we
face all problems we keep open and
honesty but like I'm not just that way
with violence on that way with sexuality
all my kids know that to have a baby to
adults have to have sex yeah like I
don't sit there and tell them there's a
stork that comes
there's no make-believe now obviously
I'm less graphic with their age that you
as we go up I mean sometimes they even
make jokes when they're young with my
eight-year-old I use the word meeting
like all you know the door [__] I can't
come in like no or you guys go over
there place why I tell my children I'm
having alone time with mommy yeah and
other parents are like you just tell you
children them all yeah that a married
couple faster you have sex together like
you don't tell your children that that's
what you guys do I mean I'm not
explaining what positions I'm putting is
not calling it like he doesn't comment
area yeah I'm like I'm like being overly
descriptive about it but there are times
where my children have to know that I
would like to be
their mother because I love her and this
is what two loving individual of the
same believe it's bad a spoon feed the
truce gradually age-appropriate rather
than to create [__] stories of that
and then Lee after tell you kids you
know everything I've told you for the
last ten years [__] actual [__]
time whereas at least ending in the bug
and said but he was telling me the truth
just not the whole entire story and said
oh yeah I mean sometimes we don't really
believe in sand summers or no you just
don't tell them Basanti no I mean they
have Center but I've never assumed it
was a real guy yeah I don't know I
managed to the way they talk and you
know it's funny cuz my children like I'm
waiting for the parents to be upset with
my kids you don't have the truth once
everyone's that know sort of spreading
it I found like I'll [__] Ramirez kids
they know it's really but I want to do
that because I don't want false
information yeah and if someone tells my
kids something crazy I want them to feel
very comfortable coming to mom and dad
to go hey I heard this I my question
hold on you know time to break out the
iPad okay no this is what is going on
and you know the only time it ever
became a little awkward I could feel the
tension from other parents whereas my
daughter was in a play I think she was
nine years old
eight and they are in the scene was
Little Orphan Annie and there's a scene
where they all have to pray right my
kids don't right here yes you know so uh
you know I'm very open if you know we
talk about different religions in the
household but my kids view religion
pretty much kind of how I do that when
someone talks about Zeus or this yeah or
Mohammed it's all kind of the same world
I will respect to other people's like
they know now that I got when she got I
realized I had to address that issue
like here we go to other people's homes
if they want to pray we're going to be
very quiet let them aside to explain
them like you know what religion was but
it was the first time I realize like oh
she don't have to start explaining this
to my kids because not that I avoided it
it's just because I don't pray in my
household can so sitting there another
girls would do this and you know my
daughter's just like what why yes so
hold on
so when you put your hands together God
hears you what if your hands are she was
just what if I did it
I'm the scintillator like only my kids
are gonna start bringing that up you
like does this affect the frequency yeah
that's so funny fader Christic just like
either I once got I'm just stood up in
assembly because I the teacher said why
do we put our hands together and we pray
and I was like just little Ariel isn't
it like God familiar to do that and she
was like stand up and get out she'd I
was taking a piss but I was like that is
only reason she was like it's to stop
little hands fiddling I was like that's
the worst way to explain that to a kid
like this is Motzkin have you got a
prediction for Jones versus cornea Jones
yeah you don't think the layoffs or
anything could I didn't call me a look
back rate in his last fight is over yeah
and I mean in Jones's younger economy
his older physical attribute wise height
wise I mean and then Daniel Cormier his
greatest strength is wrestling if right
now you told me they had to do a
wrestling match I think that John will
rightly so I mean then you add in that
okay now they can strike me kick it on
top of that Cormier just you know I mean
like you just can't compete with Jones
Jillian Conway just I think he's the
second best fighter in the world at 205
and he just happened to be born during
the time that the very best fighter 205
is around you the stuffs in the pretty
good was lost for hopefully I can say it
Jones but that one I really interested
in want I'd like this I'm not as quick
just to go ahead and go on John so much
wow this might be including Jones when
he thought worse they didn't look as
good as he used I think he fought to the
occasion yeah I think of always be would
have endangered him a little bit he made
four we would have seen him rise up but
I mean I've seen Jones do that the Jim
spar to the level of who he's fighting
you see greatest of all time is there
anyone that stands out in the old lade
hmm not yet there's so many guys that
are really good I mean you know we can
go up to weight classes you know
everything from you know ministers
Jonathan obviously is just a dynamo but
then you know Frankie Edgar I've always
been a huge fan of his abilities in
Hayes the most underrated
fighter of all time yeah maybe I mean
he's unbelievable I mean even now when
he just fought the the up-and-coming I
Yuri Rodriguez everybody the real by
training hey smash them than me
is there any fighter that you wanted to
fight but never did yet now if a door
I'd love to see the phone now hopefully
it happens whom to you who did you look
up to when you were younger
fight wise as the only fight alo
Nogueira's probably when I was 19
joining a big time watched his fights me
any fight that you won against other
fighters but then afterwards you thought
[__] hell like it was tough as [__]
like he felt like almost looking to get
up with the window or I remember the
miracle crow cup fight was very
difficult just he's very elusive and
very hard to get a hold of and you know
that was one of the few fights that you
had where people were a bit not like
they weren't really blown away by it
yeah because it was it was like he
canceled each other out a little bit you
know I mean did it a you've already said
you're going to return so that's already
been outside you think an April fellow
yeah is there a favorite fight that you
had but you look back running things
that was the one I enjoyed the most the
second Nogueira fights because it showed
that I had to overcome adversity
I got hit earlier in the fight he almost
turned around and won he put me at the
time one of his better submission holes
which is a guillotine and I was able to
fight my way through and usual roll and
runs amazing how do you feel about life
generally right now
good I wish I could travel a little bit
less and stay at home work yeah you know
I'm missing a lot of things with the
wife and kids because of you know a lot
of international travel with the ACB but
you know I'm like any man I have to
provide for my family so you know
sacrifices will be made I mean last
question there is how would you like to
be remembered um it's just somebody that
was mortal like everybody else that you
know just was very much of a scientific
approach to fight him into life alright
mate thanks very much for coming on pal
absolute pleasure thanks man
let's should appreciate appreciate very
much if you want to know more about
Frank Mir I'll put all of his links in
the description below on his podcast
phone booth fightin also those SAV
tickets the link for that will be in the
description below I hope you've enjoyed
this podcast if you have hit the like
button stare subscribe to the true
Geordie YouTube channel thanks for
watching and we'll se as well